[Musique]
personne en revanche je peux finir non
non c'est vrai merci oui à tout a été
fait signé tu fais la gueule non ça va
je fais pas la gueule je suis pas obligé
de sourire tout le temps donc d'obliger
nos fini ta soupe rien touché j'ai pas
très faim là je crois que je suis un peu
vallonné
je suis pas kraft est pas obligé de
finir tout mais vraiment j'ai envie de
vomir
elle peut plus manger de sumita gueule
toi toi dans sa réponse qu'on ait des
morts dans ce cas tu poses bordel beau
qu'est ce qui s'passe pourquoi tu veux
plus danger de soupe je veux plus lui
j'ai d'animaux c'est tout c'est juste
des terriens oui bah c'est mignon les
terriens moi j'ai pas envie qu'on me tue
j'ai l'impression de boire du sang parle
de la même chose c'est qu'on est moche
comme ses pieds les intéristes les
effets m'a serré comme tu devrais pas
tuer des êtres vivants c'est tout bon je
vois tu sais il faut savoir que ils les
ont pas du tout le même niveau de
conscience que nous les terriens c'est
tout petit c'est un cerveau minuscule sa
fabrique des voitures en métal sache il
en est qu en céramique ou d'un mois les
imaginer se faire tuer ça me suffit
voilà écoute sont très bien traités
vivent très bien
en plus ce que j'ai acheté son but vous
regarde c'est l'oeil cours dans les prix
c'est pas comme ce qu'on voit à la télé
qui s'entassent dans dix villes polluées
ne regarde cela ils sont libres et man
parfois on les tue à 16 ans super la
liberté écoute on va pas manger de la
viande avariée du coi crois qu'ils
vivent sur un caillou rond dans l'espace
ils ont pas du tout conscience qui sont
récoltées tu sais ok donc en fait plus
un animal est complet on fait ce qu'on
veut lui c'est ça dans ce cas pourquoi
ce qu'on mangerait pas boubou tu vas pas
tendre d'abobo nord coup de pub bulls à
quoi je sais pas on n'a qu'à l'écraser
comme ça il se rend compte de rien et
puis on ferait une petite purée de
boubous sait pas même sa question pense
oui d'une certaine façon tu as raison
nous sommes les assassins donc on arrête
les terriens
[Musique]
la nouvelle chaîne hbo debout cash ou
éventuellement les suivre sur tous les
réseaux sociaux on apprend ici regardez
notre vidéo comme celle du choix plus
cher en bas